I love the parental rights and education
bill I think it would do tremendous
positive things for my community when it
comes to addressing kids by their
pronouns you're seeing a big push of
this happen the reason this law which
I'm going to say that I support if they
do implement this is is they are
affirming these genders they are
affirming these pronouns outside of what
their parents are calling them and so
now you don't even have the parents
included in this conversation and
teachers are doing this behind their
back and so you have you know Ron
DeSantis coming in and saying you know
what no you shouldn't be doing this you
shouldn't be guiding you should not be
grooming these children you you should
be referring to them as they were born
because no child the reason gays against
groomer says no child is born in the
wrong body isn't to disavow that gender
dysphoria exists it's to put Force light
on that children do not have the mental
capacity to make these decisions fully
formed and educated decisions
thank you